we've heard for years I guess for eight
years - one day that the story about
President Obama is he is an autocratic
madman passing executive orders left and
right doing what he wants unchecked
dictatorial attitude towards governance
the reality is not only has President
Obama not come for all your guns yet
he's got a few hours left to do it
I'm skeptical not only has President
Obama not put everybody into FEMA camps
or turned the United States into some
kind of Marxist Kenyan Indonesian
socialist paradise unless he does that
today unless he does it today and time
is short President Obama and as far as
executive orders are concerned President
Barack Obama has averaged fewer
executive orders per year in office than
any US president in here we go now 120
years despite that some of the orders
that he has passed will no doubt be
undone by Donald Trump not all of them
can be let's take a look at some of the
numbers as of January 13th President
Obama had issued 275 executive orders
this puts him at yeah we can keep that
up at 34 executive orders per year and
just start reading back George W Bush
averaged more orders per year Clinton
George HW Bush Reagan Carter Ford Nixon
Johnson Kennedy haizen Howard Truman all
the way back to Grover Cleveland a
hundred and twenty years ago so so long
ago Pat that it didn't even fit into our
list you have to go back 120 years to
find a president that issued fewer
executive orders than Barack Obama but
but the Republican Party said he was out
of control tyranny and stuff he's Kenyan
and all that stuff guess not huh this
even surprised me though I thought
because Obama had such an obstructionist
Congress for the majority of his
presidency right and some of his a big
biggest accomplishments in a second term
at least were immigration form that was
enacted by executive order and I thought
that number would be much higher well
what you're pointing out is really
interesting which is even if it turned
out that President Obama had signed
historically a lot of executive orders
you could make the case that it was
partially related to the unprecedented
obstruction
that we saw from the Republican House
and Senate even still though that still
is not the case there's one more counter
we will hear from the sort of Obama
derangement syndrome types Obama is
hiding executive orders by not calling
them executive orders by calling them
presidential memos and the number of
presidential memos that he has signed
exceeds past presidents that's also
bogus and it's been debunked President
Obama let me take a step back presidents
can choose whether or not to make
presidential memos public and President
Obama has opted to make many of his
presidential memos public so the
allegation that Trump has signed more
presidential memos than past presidents
is only an observation of the fact that
President Obama has made public more
presidential memos than past presidents
it tells us nothing about the total
number of memos signed and just to put
this into even more context Obama seems
to have totaled 275 executive orders
yeah you look back in history FDR had
3522 it was clearly not an indication of
whether someone's a good president or
not and and particularly with FDR's
numbers think about how long he was in
office also so that also has a factor
let's see how many executive orders
Trump issues I mean if you're against
presidents acting unilaterally then you
certainly wouldn't use executive orders
yourself right oh well I guess he is
going to tomorrow he's already expected
to sign some executive orders the
argument will be well Trump had to in
order to undo the orders that President
Obama signed you're telling me that with
a Republican House and a Republican
Senate and a Republican president you're
going to need executive orders to get
things done kind of weird
and a weird doesn't really make sense to
me discuss this story and any others on
our reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash read it remember big
huge big league membership special
tomorrow just make sure you're on our
newsletter you can sign up at david
pakman.com Gamefly is sort of like
netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s